i honestly see no downside to moving to
texas especially when you got kids your
age
no are you kidding me now there's a
[ __ ] football field
i'll have a football field i'm gonna
play every sunday brian you're gonna
come over
you'll be the all-time quarterback i
guess jay's gonna move out there i want
to drop back
yeah how did it hike you know i have
good drop back
oh yeah
[Music]
blue 98 blue 98 red 15
it reminds me of that scene in longest
yard with nick with that reminds me of
the scene in longest yard with nick de
toro
he was why can i play crowd i guess here
let me tell you this
like throws the ball crazy goes there
sit down shut up
my footwork is stupid yeah dude we could
have freaking
sunday football days
barbecuing oh dude barbecue non-stop
son i got a belly how about that uh i
mean calvin got the covet test the
little
name just got swabbed up it didn't do
well with the nasal swipe no i don't do
it i don't like it
because i cuz when i broke my nose and
had it was like redone yeah me too
um i they had to pack me and unpack me
pack me again unpack me pack me again
and unpack me
i had complications i'm s it was the
worst pain i've ever been in
so i i'm reminded of that so i'm very
squeamish
i don't like [ __ ] way up my nose i wish
we filmed that you should have seen him
i was like
she was like jesus it's not that bad
yeah
oh actually makes your eyes water
[ __ ] though yeah it does my eyes
were
she said it's like like eating a bunch
of wasabi yeah oh
that's not too bad yeah it's pretty
intense i've eaten autumn
it goes away i'll take the wasabi it
goes way up your nose i don't want
things
up my nose no no i thought it was
instant results
no the antibodies i did were they the
blood yeah i don't have them
let's say they can tell if you've had it
the past week or prior weeks
how long does the day 24 to 48 hours
there you go
i got to see my parents friday they're
80.
so if you have it you're not going to go
huh my mother's so funny i was like look
i'm going to die of something so you
know
i just come yeah i know i'm saying your
mama take it
if you're older you don't want coco no
you don't you got to be very careful
so i'm going to be social distancing for
my mom and dad
you ever said on a jury no i did
attempted murder jury was it fun
no no but it was very interesting how
things how things hinged on
one little factor well you need
everybody
on one u-turn yeah but these guys were
really dangerous
they had shot a i saw the gun they shot
it wasn't it wasn't a pistol
it was a [ __ ] modified air are you
allowed to talk about the details of the
murder yeah i think so
it's all public record but they uh they
try to i've never been asked to do it if
i do i hope it's something really cool
yeah i mean it's like this i was on
zodiac i was on tv and i said i need a
sidebar i said your honor i'm
i'm an actor and i don't if these guys
are very dangerous
gang members if i convict these guys and
he goes
judge goes listen man if they're like me
i've never seen you before
oh that's fair if they're like me i
never i never heard of it hey papa don't
worry about it i was like
still though that was like i was like
that hard rock casino guy
nobody here nobody here nobody around
here ever heard of you
all right okay all right here we go
thank you dude all right thanks
what else is there a lot of uh domestic
violence in china i feel like guys like
during the long taco there during the
life yeah that's what they were saying
during the lockdown there were
a lot of instances where domestic abuse
went
up and then hit brian every day every
day
every day i want to hit him slap you
around yeah but i just i'd i'd counter
it and answer back
blink twice if you need help oh he can't
because he got his lips done
my lips my lips don't work you don't
move you can't break
goodness madness they look great bad
news is you can't blink
you'll sleep with your eyes open mm-hmm
some people sleep with their eyes open
my sister
oh that's so sweet my sister me and my
man my buddy
my buddy came up and we were looking at
my sister and she was like they're
sleeping
and my buddy goes kathleen she's just
looking at me
and he he started walking back
downstairs and bumped into me he was
this creepy man i don't want to be
honest
how's it happening the retina shuts off
oh you're dreaming
i don't know knowing her she was
probably had her eyes open just [ __ ]
looking at her for no reason jesus
christ
what else yet meanwhile i called you
today because my neck keeps catching
anybody annoying there's nothing more
annoying brian goes
uh dude my neck i go have you done
anything he goes
no dude but all the years of wrestling
and jiu jitsu my
neck hurts oh really
oh yeah i bug you oh and i
knew that would bug you hey and then now
your neck hurts and you have corona
weird dude my neck if anybody's a
physical therapist please reach out to
me
i need to figure this out because my
neck keeps catching when i go like that
it goes
and it hurts like a [ __ ] it scares me
yeah it's nothing
hey here's the other thing you don't
know
hey remember when you drove down to san
diego and you missed the podcast and you
were there for
10 hours getting all sorts of tests
turns out i'm very healthy they didn't
they didn't do any mris on your
spine or your neck or anything they did
i gotta call them and see what the [ __ ]
they saw
if they if if if you would have had like
a dead disc or something i would assume
they would have
alerted you i don't know hopefully that
would be bad to have a dead disc
what the [ __ ] is that what do they do
about that that's what i have
i mean it depends how bad it is they can
do surgery
but if you'll see on the mri it's like
there's the disc and then it's like
black it's dark
do you have that uh-huh and do you have
limited motion on your neck i don't i
don't notice that with you
uh it's a little stiff thanks travis
brown
he did that well you we're training for
it with j jake
jack mays did it jack jack
and then when i went to go shoot in on
uh travis brown he sprawled
right on my neck so that made it deeper
i remember you walking around for like
three months like
you could move your neck yeah and your
girl your girlfriend was like
why aren't you doing anything because
it'll talking about it it's not gonna
[ __ ] help it
no what are you gonna do you just gotta
be in pain all the time
that's it okay
so the next story is a couple in ohio
were running errands and they decided to
go pick up pizza from little caesars
when they
picked it up they got in the car started
driving the wife noticed that there was
a backward swatzika
on the pizza in pepperoni they ended up
reaching out to little caesars to see
how this could have happened and after
an investigation they found out that
this was an inside joke between the
workers at that particular location and
this pizza wasn't supposed to be
sold to any customer and that's the
reason why it wasn't cut
so they're saying it was an insensitive
inside joke with people who are working
that shift
and little caesars is just trying to
rectify the situation with the family
behind the scenes
did they so is that a is that a that's a
backwards swastika right
backwards which is actually the symbol
for buddhism
yeah it's a symbol for good fortune
actually yes so
right now you can see a lot of people
who right now they have stories on
they wear their then and they have that
that exact diagram
all over it yep yeah and the nazis took
it over but here's the thing though
is we're giving these little caesar
pizza employees too much credit if we
think they were doing the hindu
sign there yeah yeah
probably true
what else you got all right caesar sucks
dick anyway just
because you can eat a swastika doesn't
mean it's in good
taste but also i i thought little caesar
was
square slices did they go to round
slices oh yeah
they did a revamp recently of uh their
pizza i think it tastes better
i think i tried it maybe a couple months
ago and it was pretty good
dude i'll tell you what i did when i was
uh stressed out
a few weeks ago i uh domino's for six
nights in a row
what i do is i get a large pepperoni uh
hand tossed pizza and i put extra sauce
on it so you know that shit's fresh
and it is so goddamn good delicious when
it comes to like
fast pizza like that ain't nobody better
than dominoes
i think i want pizza now that's so nice
dude
i'm hungry that but that pizza was in
poor
taste even though they were trying to
make
pizza racism more palatable
this is the western australian premier
mark mcgowan
talking about a a kid who was rejected
from getting into a pub because of his
mullet
so the premier league i agree with that
the premiere
what's up
to start with so this is like a high
governing official right so he's a
member of the two houses of parliament
for western australia
uh that's all we need to know about this
guy so he's actually talking about it at
a press conference and it's actually
pretty funny i'll play for you
oh i just encourage people with mullets
to rise up
and rebel against these extreme
rules pubs are imposing um i think you
should be free to have a mullet we
actually answered it during a friend's
press conference too that's so funny
like well no i don't think he should be
allowed in there with a mod
that's a terrible mullet dude yeah it's
a scraggly well at least theo puts a
little effort into it
god bless him god bless that big blonde
mullet kid you see my back ripple and i
pull myself up like a chimp
like a chimp 30 times while talking to
you why wouldn't i give that to you as
it's a gift
it's a gift it's a gift